[Music]
welcome to the future of life Institute
podcast
I'm Lucas Perry today I'm excited to be
bringing you a conversation between
professor philosopher and historian
you've all know a Harare an MIT
physicist and AI researcher as well as
future of life Institute president max
tegmark Evol is the author of popular
science bestsellers sapience a brief
history of humankind homo dos a brief
history of tomorrow and of 21 lessons
for the 21st century
Max is the author of our mathematical
universe and life 3.0 being human in the
age of artificial intelligence
this episode covers a variety of topics
related to the interests and work of
both Max and Eve all it requires some
background knowledge for everything to
make sense and so I'll try to provide
some necessary information for listeners
unfamiliar with the area of Max's work
in particular here in the intro if you
already feel well acquainted with Max's
work feel free to skip ahead a minute or
use the timestamps in the description
for the podcast topics discussed in this
episode include morality consciousness
effective altruism community animal
suffering existential risk the function
of myths and stories in our world and
the benefits and risks of emerging
technology for those new to the podcast
or effective altruism effective altruism
or EA for short is a philosophical and
social movement that uses evidence and
reasoning to determine the most
effective ways of benefiting and
improving the lives of others and
existential risk is any risk that has
the potential to eliminate all of
humanity or at the very least to kill
large swathes of the global population
and leave the survivors unable to
rebuild society to current living
standards advanced emerging technologies
are the most likely source of
existential risk in the 21st century for
example through unfortunate uses of
synthetic biology nuclear weapons and
powerful future artificial intelligence
that is misaligned with human values and
objectives
the future of life Institute is a
non-profit and this podcast is funded
and supported by listeners like you so
if you find what we do on this podcast
to be important and beneficial please
consider supporting the podcast by
donating at future of life org slash
donate these contributions make it
possible for us to bring you
conversations like these and to develop
the podcast further you can also follow
us on your preferred listening platform
by searching for us directly or
following the links on the page for this
podcast found in the description and
with that here's our conversation
between max tegmark
and you vol Noah Harare maybe to start
them we're at a place where I think you
and I both agree even though it's
controversial I get the sense from
reading your books that you feel that
morality has to be grounded on
experience subjective experience which
is what I'm looking for consciousness I
love this argument you've given for
example that people who think
consciousness is just [ __ ] and
irrelevant you challenge them to tell
you what's wrong with torture if it's
just a bunch of electrons and quirks you
know moving around this way rather than
that way yeah I think that there is no
morality without consciousness and
without subjective experiences at least
for me this is very very obvious one of
my concerns again if I think about the
potential rise of AI is that AI will be
super intelligent but completely non
conscious which is something that we
never had to deal with before you know
as so much of the philosophical and
theological discussions of what happens
when there is a greater intelligence in
the world we've been discussing this for
thousands of years with God of course as
the object of discussion but the
assumption always was that this greater
intelligence would be a conscious in
some sense and be good infinitely good
and therefore I think the question we
are facing today is completely different
and to a large extent I suspect that we
are really facing philosophical
bankruptcy that what we have done for
thousands of years didn't really prepare
us for the kind
challenge that we have known and
certainly agree that we have a very
urgent challenge there I think there is
an additional risk which comes from the
fact that you know I'm embarrassed as a
scientist but we actually don't know for
sure which kinds of information
processing are conscious in which or not
from many many years I've been told for
example that it's okay to put lobsters
in hot water to boil them alive before
we eat them because they don't feel any
suffering and then I guess some guy
asked the lobster does this hurt and it
didn't say anything and it was myself
strapping argument but then there was a
recent study out that showed that
actually lobsters do feel pain and you
know they banned lobster boiling in
Switzerland now I'm very nervous
whenever we humans make these very
self-serving arguments saying oh you
know don't worry about the slaves it's
okay they don't feel they don't have it
sold they won't suffer or women don't
have a soul or animals can't suffer I'm
very nervous that we're gonna make the
same mistakes with machines just because
it's so convenient when I feel the
honest truth is yeah maybe future super
intelligent machines won't have any
experience but maybe they will and I
think we really have a moral imperative
there to do the science to answer that
question because otherwise we might be
creating enormous amounts of suffering
that we don't even know exists for this
reason and for several other reasons I
think we need to invest as much time and
energy in researching consciousness as
we do in researching and developing
intelligence if we develop sophisticated
artificial intelligence before we really
understand consciousness there is a lot
of really big ethical problems that we
just don't know how to solve one of them
is the potential existence of some kind
of consciousness in these AI systems but
there are many many others I'm so glad
to hear you say this actually because I
think we really need to distinguish
between artificial intelligence in
artificial consciousness some people
just take for granted that they're the
same thing yeah I'm really amazed by it
I'm having quite a lot of discussions
about these issues in the last two or
three years and I repeatedly amazed that
a lot of brilliant people just don't
underst
and the difference between intelligence
and consciousness when it comes up in
discussions about animals but it also
comes up in discussions about computers
and about AI to some extent the
confusion is understandable because in
humans and other mammals and other
animals consciousness and intelligence
they really go together but we can't
assume that this is Philomath nature and
that it's always like that in a very
very simple way I would say that
intelligence is the ability to solve
problems consciousness is the ability to
feel things like pain and pleasure and
love and hate now in humans and
chimpanzees and dogs and maybe even
lobsters we solve problems by having
feelings a lot of the problems we solve
who to mate with and where to invest our
money and who to vote for in the
elections we rely on our feelings to
make these decisions but computers make
decisions a completely different way at
least today very few people would argue
that computers are conscious and still
they can solve certain types of problems
much much better than we they have high
intelligence in a particular field
without having any consciousness and
maybe they will eventually reach super
intelligence without ever developing
consciousness and we don't know enough
about these ideas of consciousness and
super intelligence but it is please
feasible that you can solve all problems
better than human beings and still have
zero consciousness you just do it in a
different way just like airplanes fly
much faster than birds without ever
developing feathers right that's
definitely one of the reasons why people
are so confused there are two other
reasons I know it is also among human
very smart people while they are utterly
confused on this one is there's so many
different definitions of consciousness
some people define consciousness in a
way that's almost equivalent
intelligence but if you define it the
way you did the ability to feel things
simply having subjective experience I
think a lot of people get confused
because they have always thought of
subjective experience until
for that matter is something mysterious
that can only exist maybe in biological
organisms like to us
where's what I think was really learning
from the whole last century progress in
science is that no you know intelligence
and consciousness are all about
information processing people fall prey
to this carbon chauvinism idea that
there's only carbon or meat that can
have these traits
whereas in fact it really doesn't matter
whether the information is processed by
a carbon atom in a neuron in the brain
or by a silicon atom in a computer I'm
not sure I completely agree I mean we
still don't have enough data on that
there doesn't seem to be any reason that
we know of that consciousness would be
limited to carbon-based life forms but
so far this is the case so maybe we
don't know something my hunch is that it
could be possible to have non-organic
consciousness but until we have better
evidence there is an open possibility
that maybe there is something about
organic biochemistry which is essential
and we just don't understand and also in
the other open case we are not really
sure that consciousness is just about
information processing I mean its
present this is the dominant view in the
life sciences but we don't really know
because we don't understand
consciousness my personal hunch is that
non-organic consciousness is possible
but I wouldn't say that we know that for
certain and the other point is that
really if you think about it in the
broadest sense possible I think that
there is an entire potential universe of
different conscious states and we know
just a tiny tiny bit of it there again I
don't like thinking a little about
different life forms so human beings are
just one type of life form and there are
millions of other life forms that
existed and billions of potential life
forms that never existed but might exist
in the future and it's a bit like that
with consciousness that we really know
just human consciousness we don't
understand even the consciousness of
other animals and beyond that
potentially there is an infinite number
of conscious
so traits that never existed and might
exist in the future
I agree with all of that and I think if
you can have non-organic consciousness
artificial consciousness which would be
my guess although we don't know it I
think it's quite clear then that the
mind space possible artificial
consciousness is vastly larger than
anything that evolution has given us so
we have to have a very open mind if we
simply take away from this that we
should understand which entities
biological and otherwise are conscious
and can experience suffering pleasure
and so on and we try to base our
morality on this idea that we want to
create more positive experiences and
eliminate suffering then this leads
straight into what I find very much at
the core of the so-called effective
altruism community which we are with the
future life is Deutz view ourselves as a
part of where the idea is we want to
help do what we can to make a future
that's good in that sense lots of
positive experience is not negative ones
and we want to do it effectively you
want to put our limited time and money
and so on into those efforts which will
make the biggest difference and the EA
community has a number of years been
highlighting a top three list of issues
that they feel are the ones that are
most worth putting effort into in this
sense one of them is global health which
is very very non-controversial right
another one is animal suffering and
reducing it and the third one is
preventing life from going each states
doing something stupid with technology a
very curious whether you feel that the
EI movement is basically picked out the
correct three things to focus on or
whether you have things you would
subtract from that lists or add to it
global health animal suffering extra
such
well you know I think that nobody can do
everything so whether you're an
individual or an organization it's a
good idea to pick a good cause and then
focus on it and not spend too much time
wondering about all the other things
that you might do I mean these three
causes are certainly some of the most
important in the world I would just say
that about the first one it's not easy
at all to determine what are the goals I
mean as long as health means simply
fighting illnesses and sicknesses and
bringing people up to what is considered
as a normal level of health then that's
not very problematic but in the coming
decades I think that the healthcare
industry would focus more and more not
on fixing problems but rather on
enhancing abilities enhancing
experiences enhancing bodies and brains
and minds and so forth and that's much
much more complicated both because of
the potential issues of inequality and
simply that we don't know where to aim
for
one of the reason that when you ask me
at first about morality I focused on
suffering and not on happiness is that
suffering is in France clear concept
than happiness and that's why when you
talk about health care if you think
about this image of the line of normal
health like the baseline of what's a
healthy human being it's much easier to
deal with things falling under this line
then things that potentially are above
this line so I think even this first
issue it will become extremely
complicated in the communicates and then
for the second issue on animal suffering
you've used some pretty strong words
before you've said that industrial
farming is one of the worst crimes in
history and we've called the faith of
industrially farmed animals one of the
most pressing ethical questions of our
time a lot of people would be quite
shocked when they hear you using such
strong words about this since they
routinely eat that we farm meat how do
you explain to them this is quite
straightforward I mean we are talking
about billions upon billions of animals
the majority of large animals today in
the world are either unions or our
domesticated animals cows and pigs and
chickens and so forth and so we're
talking about a lot of animals and we
are talking about a lot of pain and
misery the industrial farmed cow and
chicken are probably competing for the
title of the most miserable creature
that ever existed they are capable of
experiencing a wide range of sensations
and emotions and in most of these
industrial facilities they are
experiencing the worst possible
sensations and emotions in my case
you're preaching to the choir here I
find this so disgusting my wife and I
just decided to mostly be vegan I don't
go preach to other people about what
they should do but I just don't want to
be part of this it reminds me so much
also things you've written about
yourself about how people used to
justify having slaves before they say oh
it's the white man's burden we're
helping the slaves it's good for them
and much the same way now we make these
very self-serving arguments for why we
should be doing this
what you personally take away from this
thing do you eat meat now for example
personally I define myself as vegan ish
I mean I'm not strictly vegan I don't
want to make kind of religion out of it
and start thinking in terms of purity
and whatever I try to limit as far as
possible my involvement with industries
that harm animals for no good reason and
it's not just meat and dairy in eggs it
can be other things as well the chains
of causality in the world today are so
complicated that you cannot really
extricate yourself completely it's just
impossible
so for me and also what I tell other
people is just do your best and don't
make it into a kind of religious issue
if somebody comes and tell you that you
know I'm now thinking about this animal
suffering and I decided to have one day
a week without meat then don't start
blaming this person for eating meat the
other six days just gonna graduate them
I'm making one step in the right
direction
yeah that sounds not just like good
morality but also like good psychology
if you actually want to dodge things in
the right direction and then coming to
the third one existential risk there I
love how Nick Bostrom asks us to compare
this to scenario is one in which some
calamity kills 99% of all people and
another where it kills a hundred percent
of all people and they asks how much
worse is the second one the point being
obviously as you know that if we kill
everybody
we might actually forfeits having
billions or quadrillions or more of
future Minds in the future experiencing
all these amazing things for billions of
years this is not something I've seen
you talk as much about and you're
writing it so I'm very curious how you
think about this morally how you weigh
future experiences that could exist
versus the ones that we know exist now I
don't really know I don't think that we
understand consciousness and experience
well enough to even start making such
calculations in general my suspicion at
least based on on our current knowledge
is that it's simply not a mathematical
entity that can be calculated so you
know all these philosophical riddles
that people sometimes enjoy so much
debate
about whether you know you have five
people of this kind of hundred people of
that kind and who should you save and
and so forth and so on it's all based on
the assumption that experience is a
mathematical entity that can be added
and subtracted and my suspicion is that
it's just not like that to some extent
yes we make these kinds of comparison
and calculations all the time but on a
deeper level I think it's taking us in
the wrong direction at least at our
present level of knowledge it's not like
eating ice cream is one point of
happiness killing somebody is a million
points of misery so if by killing
somebody we can allow 1 million and one
persons to enjoy ice cream it's worth it
I think the problem here is not that we
given the wrong points to the different
experiences it's just that it's not a
mathematical entity in the first place
and I know that in some cases we have to
do these kinds of calculations but I
would be extremely careful about it and
I would definitely not use it as the
basis for building entire moral and
philosophical projects I certainly agree
with you that it's extremely difficult
set of questions you get into with each
try to trade off positives against
negatives like you mentioned in the ice
cream versus murder case there but I
still feel that all-in-all as a species
we tend to be a little bit too sloppy
and flippant about the future and maybe
partly because we haven't evolved to
think so much about what happens in
billions of years anyway
and if we look at how reckless we've
been with nuclear weapons for example I
recently was involved with the
organization of giving us a word to
honor
Vasili arkhipov who quite likely
prevented nuclear war between the US and
the Soviet Union and most people hadn't
even heard about that for 40 years more
people have heard of Justin Bieber than
the Vasili arkhipov even though I would
argue that I would really unambiguously
been a really really bad thing and that
we should celebrate people who do
courageous acts that the prevent nuclear
war for instance and in the same spirit
I often feel concerned that there's so
little attention even paid to risks that
we drive ourselves extinct or cause
giant catastrophe
- how much attention we paid with
Kardashians or whether we can get 1%
less unemployment next year some curious
if you have some sympathy for my angst
here or whether you think I'm
overreacting
I completely agree I often define it
that we are now kind of irresponsible
gods certainly with regard to the other
animals and the ecological system and
with regard to ourselves we have really
divine powers of creation and
destruction but we don't take our job
seriously enough we tend to be very
irresponsible in our thinking getting
our behavior on the other hand part of
the problem is that the number of
potential apocalypses is growing
exponentially over the last 50 years and
as scholar and as a communicator I think
it's part of our job to be extremely
careful in the way that we discuss this
issue with the general public and it's
very important to focus the discussion
on the more likely scenarios because if
we just go on bombarding people with all
kinds of potential scenarios of complete
destruction
very soon we just lose people's
attention they become actually
pessimistic that everything is hopeless
so why worry about all that so I think
part of the job of the scientific
community and people who deal with these
kinds of issues is to really identify
the most likely scenarios and focus the
discussion on that even if there are
some other scenarios which have a small
chance of occurring and completely
destroying all of humanity and maybe all
of life but we just can't deal with
everything at the same time I completely
agree with that with one caveat I think
it's very much in the spirit of
effective altruism what you said we want
to focus on the things that really
mattered the most and not turn everybody
into hypochondriac paranoia made getting
worried about everything the one caveat
that would give is we shouldn't just
look at the probability of each bad
thing happened but we should look at the
expected damage will do so the
probability times how bad it is I agree
because nuclear war for example maybe
the chance of having next
nuclear war between the US and Russia is
only 1% per year or 10% per year or one
in a thousand per year but if you have
the nuclear winter caused by certain
smoke in the atmosphere and are blocking
out the Sun for years that could easily
kill 7 billion people so most people on
earth and masturbation because it would
be about 20 or Celsius colder that means
that on average if it's 1% chance per
year which seems small you're still
killing on average 70 million people
that's the number that sort of matters I
think that means we should make it a
high priority to reduce that more with
nuclear war I would say that we are not
concerned enough I mean too many people
including politicians have this weird
impression that well nuclear wow that's
history no that was in the 60s and 70s
people worried about it's exactly it's
not a 21st century issue you know this
is ridiculous we are now even greater
danger at least in terms of the
technology then we were in the Cuban
Missile Crisis but you must remember
this in Stanley Kubrick to cross
Strangelove or one of my favorite films
of all time yes so the subtitle of the
film is how I stopped fearing and
learned to love the bomb with a dessert
and the funny thing is it actually
happened people have stopped fearing
them maybe they don't love it very much
but compared to the 50s and 60s people
just don't talk about it like you look
at the Black Sea debate in Britain and
Britain is one of the leading nuclear or
powers in the world and it's not even
mentioned it's not part of the
discussion anymore and that's very
problematic because I think this is a
very serious existential threat but I'll
take a counter example which is in the
field of AI even though I understand the
philosophical importance of discussing
the possibility of general AI emerging
in the future and then rapidly taking
over the world and you know all the
paperclip scenarios in so forth I think
that at the present moment it really
distracts attention of people from the
immediate dangers of the AI arms race
which have a far far higher chance of
materializing in the next say 10 20 30
years
and we need to focus people's minds on
these short-term dangers and I know that
there is a small chance that general AI
would be upon us say in the next thirty
years but I think it's a very very small
chance whereas the chance that's kind of
primitive a I would completely disrupt
the economy the political system and
human life in the next thirty years is
about a hundred percent it's bound to
happen yeah and I very far more about
what primitive AI will do to the job
market to the military to people's daily
lives
then about general AI appearing in the
more distant future yeah a few reactions
to this we can talk more about
artificial general intelligence and
super intelligence later if we get time
but there was a recent survey of AI
researchers around the world asking what
they thought and I was interested to
know the nasty
most of them guess that we will get
artificial general intelligence within
decades so I wouldn't say that the
chance is small but I would agree with
you that it's certainly not going to
happen tomorrow but if we die right them
as you and I meditate go to the gym it's
quite likely we will actually get to
experience it but more importantly
coming back to what you said earlier I
see all of these risks is really being
one and the same risk in the sense that
what's happened that is of course that
science has kept getting every more
powerful and science that there
forgivers have more powerful technology
and you know I I love technology I'm a
nerd they work at the University that
has technology in its name and I'm
optimistic we can trade inspiring
high-tech future for life if we win what
I like to call the wisdom race the race
between the growing power of the
technology and the going wisdom with
which management or putting it in your
words that you just used there you
missing you learn to take more seriously
our job as stewards of this planet you
can slip suit at every science and see
exactly the same thing happening we
physicists a kind of proud that we gave
the world cellphones and computers and
lasers but our problem child has been
nuclear energy
and nuclear weapons in particular
chemists are proud that they gave the
world always need great new materials
and their problem child is climate
change
biologists in my book I should have done
the best so far they actually got
together in the 70s and persuaded
leaders to ban biological weapons and
drug clear redline more broadly between
what was acceptable and unacceptable
uses of biology and that's why today
most people think of biology is really a
force for good
something that cures people and helps
them live healthier lives and I think a
RI is right now lagging a little bit in
time it's finally getting to the point
where they're starting to have an impact
and they're rappeling with the same kind
of question they haven't had big
disasters yet so they're in the biology
camp there but they're trying to figure
out where do they draw a line between
acceptable and unacceptable uses so you
don't get a crazy military anti arms
race and lethal force weapons so you
don't trade very destabilizing income
inequality so that AI doesn't treat 1984
on steroids etc and I wanted to ask you
about what sort of new story as a
society you feel we need in order to
tackle these challenges I've been very
very persuaded by your arguments that
stories are so central to society
first the collaborate and accomplish
that but you've also made a really
compelling case I think that the most
popular recent stories are getting less
powerful for popular communism there's a
lot of disappointment and this
liberalism and it feels like a lot of
people are kind of craving for a new
story that involves technology somehow
and but can help us get our act together
and also help us feel meaning purpose in
this world but I've never in your books
seen a clear answer to what you feel
that this new story should be because I
don't know if I knew the new story I
will tell it I think we are now in the
kind of double bind right now we have to
fight on two different fronts on the one
hand we are witnessing in the last few
years the collapse of the last big
modern story of liberal democracy and
liberalism more generally which has been
I would say as a historian the best
story humans ever came up with
and it did create the best world that
humans ever enjoyed I mean the world of
the late 20th century and early 21st
century with all its problems it's still
better for humans not for cows or
chickens for humans it's still better
than at any previous moment in history
not many problems but anybody who says
that this was a bad idea I would like to
hear which year are you thinking about
as a better year now in 2019 when was it
better in 1919 in 1719 in 1219 I mean
for me this is obvious this has been the
best story we have come up with that's
so true I have to just admit it whenever
I read the news for too long I start
getting depressed but then I always
cheer myself up by reading history and
remind myself that never fails in the
last four years have been quite bad
things of the terior rating but we are
still better off than in any previous
era but people are losing faith in this
story we are reaching really a situation
of zero story all the big stories of the
20th century have collapsed or our
collapsing and the vacuum is currently
filled by nostalgic fantasies
nationalistic and religious fantasies
which simply don't offer any real
solutions to the problems of the 21st
century so on the one hand we have the
task of supporting or reviving the
Liberal Democratic system which is dull
for the only game in town I keep
listening to the critics and they have a
lot of valid criticism but I'm waiting
for the alternative and the only thing I
hear is completely unrealistic nostalgic
fantasies about going back to some past
golden era that as historian I know was
far far worse and even if it was not so
far worse he just can't go back there
you can't recreate the 19th century of
the Middle Ages under the conditions of
the 21st century it's impossible so we
have this one struggle to maintain what
we have already achieved but then at the
same time on a much deeper level my
suspicion is the liberal stories
know it at least is really not up to the
challenges of the 21st century because
it's built on foundations that the new
science and especially the new
technologies of artificial intelligence
and bioengineering are just destroying
the belief we are inherited in the
autonomous individual in free will in
all these basically liberal authorities
they will become increasingly untenable
in contact with new powerful
bioengineering and artificial
intelligence to put it in a very very
concise way I think we are entering the
era of hacking human beings not just
hacking smartphones and bank accounts
but really hacking Homo sapiens which
was impossible before I mean AI gives us
the computing power necessary and
biology gives us the necessary
biological knowledge and when you
combine the two you get the ability to
hack human beings and if you continue to
try and build society on the
philosophical ideals of the 18th century
about the individual and free will and
and all that in a world where it's
feasible technically to hack millions of
people systematically it's just not
going to work and we need an updated
story I'll just finish the diss note and
our problem is that we need to defend
the story from the nostalgic fantasies
at the same time that we are replacing
it by something else and it's just very
very difficult when I began writing my
books like five years ago
I thought the real project was to really
go down to the foundations of the
liberal story exposed the difficulties
and build something new and then you had
all these nostalgic Papa lists eruption
or last four or five years and I
personally find myself more and more
engaged in defending the old-fashioned
liberal story instead of replacing it
intellectually it's very frustrating
because I think they're really important
intellectual work is finding out in your
story but politically it's far more
urgent if we allow the emergence of some
kind of populist
thorry towering regimes then whatever
comes out of it will not be a better
story yeah unfortunately I agree with
your assessment here I love to travel
I work in basically the United Nations
like environment that my university with
students from all around the world in it
I have this very strong sense that
people are feeling increasingly lost
around the world today because the
stories that used to give them a sense
of purpose and meaning and so on are so
dissolving in front of their eyes and of
course we don't like to feel lost then
likely to jump on whatever branches are
held out for us and and they are often
just retrograde things let's go back to
the good ol days and also to other
unrealistic things but I agree with you
that the rise in population we see now
is not the cause it's a symptom of
people feeling lost so I think it was a
little bit unfair to ask you a few
minutes to answer the toughest question
of our time what should our new story be
but maybe we can break it into pieces a
little bit and say what are these some
elements that we would like the new
story to have for example it should
accomplish course multiple things it has
to incorporates technology in a
meaningful way which our past stories
did not and has to incorporate my
process progress and biotech for example
it also has to be a truly global story I
think this time which isn't just a story
about how America's gonna get better or
for China's gonna get better off but one
about how we're all gonna get better off
together and we can put up a whole bunch
of other requirements if we start maybe
with this part about the global nature
of the story people disagree violently
about so many things around the world
but are there any ingredients at all of
a story that you think people around the
world would already agree to some
principles or ideas again I don't really
know I mean I don't know what the news
story would look like
historically these kinds of really grand
narratives they aren't created by two or
three people having a discussion and
thinking okay what news stories it
should we tell it's far deeper and more
powerful forces that come together to
create these new stories I mean even
trying to say okay we don't have the
full view but let's try to put a few
ingredients in place the whole thing
about this story is that the whole comes
before the parts the narrative is far
more important than the individual facts
that build it up so I'm not sure that we
can start creating the story by just
okay let's put the first few sentences
and who knows how it will continue you
wrote books I write books we know that
the first few sentences are the last
sentences only when you know how the
whole book is going to look like but
then you go back at the beginning and
you ride the first few sentences
yeah it's sometimes the very last thing
you write there's the new title so I
agree that whatever the new story is
going to be it's going to be global the
world is now too small and too
interconnected to have just a story for
one part of the world it won't work and
also it will have to take very seriously
both the most updated science and the
most updated technology something that
you know liberal democracy is we know it
it's basically still in the 18th century
it's taking an 18th century story and
simply following it to its logical
conclusions for me the maybe the most
amazing thing about liberal democracy is
it really completely disregarded all the
discoveries of the life sciences over
the last two centuries and of the
technical sciences I mean as if Darvin
never existed and we know nothing about
evolution I mean you can basically meet
these folks from the middle of the 18th
century whether it's through so jeffra
song and all these guys and they'll be
surprised by some of the conclusions we
have drawn from the basis they provided
us but fundamentally it's nothing has
changed
Darvin didn't really change anything
computers didn't really change anything
and I think the next story won't have
that luxury of being able to ignore the
discoveries of Science and Technology
the number one thing we'll have to take
into account is how do humans live in a
world when there is somebody out there
that knows you better than you know
yourself
but that somebody isn't God that
somebody is a technological system which
might not be a good system at all that's
a question we never had to face before
we could always comfort herself with the
idea that we are kind of a black box to
the rest of humanity nobody could really
understand me better than I understand
myself the king the emperor the church
they don't really know what's happening
within me maybe God knows so we had a
lot of discussions about what to do is
that the existence of a God who knows us
better than we know ourselves but we
didn't really have to deal with an on
divine system that can hack us and this
system is emerging I think it will be in
place within our lifetime in contrast to
generally artificial intelligence that
I'm skeptical whether I'll see it in my
lifetime I'm convinced we will see if we
live long enough a system that knows us
better than we know ourselves and the
basic premises of democracy of
free-market capitalism even if religion
just don't work in such a world right
how does democracy function in a world
when somebody understands a voter better
than the voter understands herself or
himself and the same is the free market
I mean if the customer is not right if
the algorithm is right then we need a
completely different economic system
that's the big question that I think we
should be focusing on I don't have the
answer but whatever story will be
relevant to the 21st century will have
to answer this question I certainly
agree with you that democracy has
totally failed to adapt to the
developments of the life sciences and I
would add to that to the developments in
the Natural Sciences - I watched all of
the debates between Trump and Clinton in
the last election here in the US and I
didn't know his artificial
religions getting mentioned even a
single time not even when they talked
about jobs and the voting system we have
you know an electro college system here
where it doesn't even matter how people
vote except in a few swing states where
there's so little influence from the
voter to what actually happens even
though we now have blockchain and could
easily implement eckel solutions where
people will be able to have much more
influence this reflects that we
basically this declare victory on earth
democratic system 100 years ago and have
it updated and I'm very interested in
how we can dramatically revamp it if we
believe in some form of democracy so
that we actually can have more influence
on power societies run as individuals
and how we can have good reason to
actually trust the system if it is able
to help us you know that is actually
working in our best interest there's a
key tenant in religions that you're
supposed to be able to trust the God as
having your best interest in mind right
I think many people in the world today
do not trust that their political
leaders actually have their best
interest in mind the certainly I mean
that's the issue you give a really
divine powers too far from divine
systems
we shouldn't be too pessimistic I mean
the technology is not inherently evil
either and what history teaches us about
technology is that technology is also
never deterministic you can use the same
technologies to create very different
kinds of societies we saw that in the
20th century when the same technologies
were used to build communist
dictatorships and liberal democracies
there was no real technological
difference between the USSR and the USA
it was just people making different
decisions what to do is the same
technology I don't think that the new
technology is inherently anti-democratic
or inherently anti-liberal it really is
about choices that people make even in
what kind of technological tools to
develop if I think about again AI in
surveillance at present we see all over
the world that corporations and
governments are developing AI tools to
monitor individuals but technically we
can do exactly the opposite we can
create tools that monitoring survey
government and corporations in the
service of individuals for instance to
fight corruption in the government as an
individual it's very difficult for me to
say monitor nepotism politicians
appointing all kinds of family members
to lucrative positions in the government
or in the civil service but it should be
very easy to build an AI tool that goes
over the immense amount of information
involved and in the end you just get a
simple application on your smartphone
you enter the names of politician and
you immediately see within two seconds
who he appointed was she appointed from
their family and friends to what
positions it should be very easy to do
it I don't see the Chinese government
creating such an application any time
soon but people can create it or if you
think about the fake news epidemic
basically what's happening is that
cooperation that governments are hacking
us in their service but the technology
can work the other way around
we can develop an anti-virus for the
mind the same way we developed antivirus
for the computer
we need to develop an anti-virus for the
mind an AI system that serves me and not
a corporation or a government and it
gets to know my weaknesses in order to
protect me against manipulation at
present what's happening is that the
hackers are hacking me they get to know
my weaknesses and that's how they are
able to manipulate me for instance with
fake news if they discover that I
already have a bias against immigrants
they show me one fake news story maybe
about a group of immigrants raping local
women and I easily believe that because
I already have despised my neighbor may
have an opposite bias she may think that
anybody who opposes immigration is a
fascist and the same hunkers will find
that out and will show her a fake news
story about I don't know right-wing
extremists murdering immigrants and she
will believe that and then if I meet my
neighbor there is no way we can have a
conversation about immigration now we
can and should develop an AI system that
serves me and my neighbor and alerts us
look somebody is trying to hack you
somebody is trying to manipulate you and
if we learn to trust this system that it
serves us it doesn't serve any
cooperation of government it's an
important tool in protecting our minds
from being manipulated another tool in
the same field we are now basically
feeding enormous amounts of mental junk
food to our bodies right we spent hours
every day basically feeding our hatred
our fear our anger and that's a terrible
and stupid thing to do the thing is that
people discovered that the easiest way
to grab our attention is by pressing the
hate button in the mind or the fear
button in the mind and we are very
vulnerable to that now just imagine that
somebody develops a tool that shows you
what's happening to your brain or to
your mind as you are watching these
YouTube clips maybe doesn't block you
it's not Big Brother that
knocks all these things it's just like
when you buy a product and it shows you
how many calories are in the product and
how much saturated fat in how much sugar
there is in the product so at least in
some cases you learn to make better
decisions just imagine that you have
this small window in in your computer
which tells you what's happening to your
brain is you're watching this video and
what's happening to your levels of
hatred or fear or anger and then make
your own decision but at least you are
the more aware of what kind of food
you're giving to your mind yeah this is
something I am also very interested in
seeing world AI systems that empower the
individual and all the ways that you
mentioned we're very interested in the
future life Institute actually in
supporting this kind of thing the nerdy
technical side and I think this also
drives home this very important fact
that technology is not good or evil
technology is an amoral tool that can be
used or for good things and for bad
things that's exactly why I feel it's so
important that we develop the wisdom to
use it for good things rather than bad
things so in that sense AI is no
different than fire which can be used
for good things or bad things or but we
as a society have developed a lot of
wisdom now in fire management's we
educate our kids about it we have fire
extinguishers and fire trucks and with
artificial intelligence another powerful
Technic feel we need to do better and
similarly developing the wisdom
it's--there the technology puts better
uses now we're reaching the end of the
hour here I'd like to just finish with
two more of questions one of them is
about what we wanted to ultimately mean
to be human as we get evermore text you
put it so it beautifully and I think you
as sapiens that that progress is
gradually taking us beyond asking why we
want to asking is that what we wants to
want yeah and I guess even more broadly
how we want to brand ourselves how we
want to think about ourselves as humans
in a high-tech future
I'm quite curious first of all you
personally if you think about yourself
in 30 years 40 years what do you want to
want and what sort of society would you
like to live in and say 2060 if you
could have it your way it's a profound
question it's a difficult question my
initial answer is that I would really
like not just to know the truth about
myself but to want to know the truth
about myself usually the main obstacle
in knowing the truth about yourself is
that you don't want to know it it's
always accessible to you I mean we've
been told for thousands of years by you
know all the big names in philosophy and
religion almost all say the same thing
get to know yourself better it's maybe
the most important thing in life we
haven't really progressed touched in the
last thousands of years and the reason
is that yes we keep getting this advice
but we don't really want to do it
working on our motivation in this field
I think would be very good for us it
will also protect us from all the naive
utopias which tend to draw far more of
our attention when especially as
technology will give us all at least
some of us more and more power the
temptations of naive utopias are going
to be more and more irresistible and I
think that really most powerful check on
these naive utopias is really getting to
know yourself better
would you like what it means to be you
vowel 2060 to be more on the hedonistic
side that you have all these blissful
experiences and serene meditation and so
on or would you like there to be a lot
of challenges in there that gives you
sense meaning your purpose would you
like to be somehow upgraded with
technology none of the above I mean at
least if I think deeply enough about
these issues yes I would like to be
upgraded but only in the right way and
I'm not sure what the right way is I'm
not a great believer in blissful
experiences in meditation or otherwise
they tend to be traps that this is what
we've been looking for you know for all
our lives and for millions of years all
the animals they just constantly look
for blissful experiences and after a
couple of million different years of
evolution
it doesn't seem that the brings us
anymore and especially in meditation you
learn these kind of blissful experiences
can be the most deceptive because you
fall under the impression that this is
the goal that you should be aiming it
like this is a really good meditation
this is a really deep meditation simply
because you're very pleased with
yourself and then you spend countless
hours later on trying to get back there
or regretting that you're not there and
in the end it's just another experience
what we experience right now when we are
now talking on the phone to each other
and I feel something in my stomach and
you feel something in your head this is
as special and amazing is the most
blissful experience of meditation the
only difference is that we've gotten
used to it so we are not amazed by it
but right now we are experiencing the
most amazing thing in the universe and
we just take it for granted partly
because we are distracted by this notion
that out there there is something really
really special that we should be
experiencing so I'm a bit suspicious of
blissful experiences again I would just
basically repeat that to really
understand yourself also means to really
understand the nature of these
experiences and if you really
and that then so many of these big
questions will be answered
similarly the question that we dealt
with in the beginning of how to evaluate
different experiences and what kind of
experiences should we be creating for
humans offal artificial consciousness
for that you need to deeply understand
the nature of experience otherwise there
are so many naive utopias that can tempt
you so I would focus on that when I say
that I want to know the truth about
myself it's really also it means to
really understand the nature of these
experiences to my very last question
coming back to this story and ending on
a positive inspiring note I've been
thinking back about when new stories led
to very positive change and I started
thinking about a particular Swedish
story so the year was 1945 people were
looking at each other all over Europe
saying huh we screwed up again how about
we instead of using all this great
technology people were sending them but
to build ever more powerful weapons how
about we instead use it to create a
society that benefits everybody where we
can have free health care free
University for everybody free retirement
and build the real welfare state and I'm
sure there were a lot of promotions
around is that I know that's just
hopeless naive dreamer II you know those
smoked some weed and hug a tree because
it's never gonna work right but this
story this optimistic vision was
sufficiently concrete and sufficiently
book bold annulus thick seeming but it
actually caught on you know we did this
in Sweden and it actually conquered the
world not like when the Vikings tried
and failed to do it with swords but this
idea conquered the world right so narrow
so many rich countries have copied this
idea
I keep wondering if there is another new
vision or story like this some sort of
welfare 3.0 which incorporates all of
the exciting new technologies happen
since 45 on the biotech side on the AI
side etc to envision if society which is
truly bold and sufficiently appealing to
people around the world that people
could rally around this I feel that the
shared positive experience is something
more than anything else can really help
foster collaboration around
world and I'm curious what you would say
in terms of do you think it was a bold
positive vision for the planet now going
away from what you spoke about earlier
with yourself personally getting to know
yourself and so on I think we can aim
towards what you define is well for 3.0
which is again based on a better
understanding of humanity the welfare
state which many countries have built
over the last decades have been an
amazing human achievement and it
achieved many concrete results in in
fields that when you want to aim for
like in health care so ok let's
vaccinate all the children in the
country and let's make sure everybody
has enough to eat we succeeded in doing
that and the kind of welfare 3.0 program
would try to expand that to other fields
in which our achievements are far more
moderate simply because we don't know
what to aim for we don't know what we
need to do if you think about mental
health it's much more difficult than
providing food to people because we have
a very poor understanding of the human
mind and of what mental health is even
if you think about food one of the
scandals of science is that we still
don't know what to eat so we basically
solved the problem of enough food now
actually we have the opposite problem of
people eating too much and not too
little
but beyond the medical quantity it's I
think one of the biggest scandals of
science that after centuries we still
don't know what we should eat and mainly
because and so many of these miracle
diets they are a one-size-fits-all as if
everybody should eat the same thing
whereas obviously it should be tailored
to individuals so if you harness the
power of AI and Big Data machine
learning and biotechnology you could
create the best dietary system in the
world that tell people individually what
would be good for them to eat and this
will have enormous side benefits in
reducing medical problems in reducing
waste of food and resources helping the
climate crisis and so forth so this is
just one example yeah just on that
example are you also that part of the
problem is beyond that we just the
no in US that actually there are a lot
of lobbyists who are telling people what
to eat knowing full well that that's bad
for them just because that way they'll
make more of a profit which gets back to
your question they're happy how we can
prevent ourselves from getting hacked by
powerful forces that don't have our best
interest in mind but the the things you
mentioned seemed like a little bit of
first world perspective was it easy to
get when we live in Israel or Sweden but
of course there many people on the
planet who still live in pretty
miserable situations where we actually
can quite easily articulate how to make
things at least a bit better but then
also in our societies I mean you touched
on mental health there's a significant
rise in depression in the United States
life expectancy in the US has gone down
three years in a row which does not
suggest the people are getting happier
here I'm wondering if you also in your
positive vision of the future that we
can hope we end on here would one throw
in some ingredients about a sort of
society where we don't just have the
lowest rung of the Maslow pyramid taking
care of the food and shelter stuff but
also feel meaning in purpose and
meaningful connections with our fellow
platforms I think it's not just a
first-world issue again even if you
think about food even in developing
countries more people today die from
diabetes and diseases related to
overeating Oh to overweight then from
starvation and mental health issues are
certainly not just the problem for the
first world people are suffering from
that in all countries part of the issue
is that mental health is far far more
expensive certainly if you think in
terms of going to therapy once or twice
a week than just giving vaccinations
around a biotics so it's much more
difficult to create a robust mental
health system in poor countries but we
should aim there it's certainly not just
for the first world and if we really
understand humans better we can provide
much better health care both physical
health and mental health for everybody
on the planet not just for Americans or
Israelis or all Swedes
in terms of physical health it's usually
a lot cheaper and simpler to not treat
the diseases but to instead prevent them
from happening in the first place by
reducing smoking reducing people eating
extremely unhealthy foods etc in the
same way with mental health presumably a
key driver of a lot of the problems we
have is that we have put ourselves in a
human-made environment which is
incredibly different from the
environment that we evolved to flourish
in and I'm wondering rather than just
trying to develop new pills to help us
live in this environment which is often
optimized for ability to produce stuff
rather than for human happiness if you
think that by deliberately changing your
environment to be more conducive to
human happiness might improve our
happiness a lot without having to you
know treat it's treat mental health
disorders it will demand the enormous
amounts of resources and energy but if
you are looking for a big project for
the 21st century then yeah that's
definitely a good project to undertake
ok that's probably a good challenge from
you on which to end this conversation
I'm extremely grateful for both of you
about these things these are ideas
continue thinking about great enthusiasm
for a long time to come and I very much
hope we can stay in touch and actually
meet in person even before too long yeah
thank you for hosting me I really can't
think of anyone on the planet who thinks
more soundly about the big picture the
human condition here than you but such
an honor thank you it was a pleasure for
me too not a lot of opportunities to
really go deeply about these issues I
mean usually we could pull the way to
questions about the 2020 presidential
elections and things like that which is
important but no we still have also to
give some time to the big picture
yeah once again tada
thank you so much
thanks so much for tuning in and being a
part of our final episode of 2019 many
well and warm wishes for a happy and
healthy New Year from myself and the
rest of the future of life Institute
team this podcast is possible because of
the support of listeners like you so if
you found this podcast and conversation
to be meaningful or valuable consider
supporting it directly by donating at
future of life org slash donate
contributions like yours make these
conversations possible